a bit of breaking news that we can bring
you staying with politics but of a very
different tone the former MP and the
two-time academy award-winning actress
Glenda Jackson has died she died
peacefully this morning apparently at
her home in Blackheath in London this is
coming from her agent Lionel Lana they
say that she died with her family at her
side she had only just recently finished
uh filming at the great escaper in which
she co-starred with Michael Kane so we
can certainly expect there to be
tributes in the House of Commons for the
two-time Academy award-winning actress
and politician Glenda Jackson who it has
been announced in the last few minutes
by her agent has passed away at her home
in London
uh so let's just remind you of that
breaking news which is coming to us
which is that Glenda Jackson who was an
actress uh she wanted two Academy Awards
but she was also a politician a former
member of parliament uh also one of the
few artists to received the Triple Crown
of acting having won two Academy Awards
three Emmy Awards and a Tony Awards she
was made a commander at the order of the
British Empire by the queen back in 1978
and that was all before her political
career she took a Hiatus from axon to
take on this career in politics from
1992 to 2015 she was a labor MP of
course for Hampstead and Highgate in the
1992 general election she served as
Junior transport Minister during the
government of Tony Blair but later did
become a Critic of him and she
represented Hampstead and Kilburn from
2010 and then at the 2010 general
election she was it was one of the
closest at the election she stood down
in the 2015 general election and of
course as we've just said returned to
action to acting she has died at her
home in London her family by her side
after a very brief illness at the age of
87.
foreign